yank speaks is sponsored by expressvpn
protect your online privacy today at
expressvpn.com
yang
[Music]
[Applause]
so i have to to comment on your t-shirt
i think it says immigrants feed
uh america which i could not agree more
with
and you have such an incredible personal
narrative yourself
you came to this country with next to
nothing
listen as an immigrant i'm very thankful
about the amazing opportunity
i gain by being invited to join this
country
i always say that the immigration reform
is not a problem for america to solve
it's an opportunity for america to cease
dreamers should be part of the american
dream
today who people think is being feeding
america through this pandemic
the people that are that we can afford
to be playing golf who do you think is
taking care of those golf courses
who do you think is refilling the
shelves who do you think is working the
farms
every day from sunrise to sunset
sometimes uh badly paid badly treated
without any ppe to make them safe
who do you think 11 million undocumented
americans
i am telling you they've been in every
corner of america through this pandemic
moving america forward those men and
women they show the value to america
they show that they belong to america is
about time that once and for all
we pass comprehensive immigration reform
america will win
republicans and democrats will win
i am thrilled to welcome to yang speaks
uh celebrity chef humanitarian activist
entrepreneur jose andres
uh wow jose it's so great to connect
with you
you've been one of the great success
stories of
the culinary world but also
entrepreneurship more broadly
and humanitarianism and i know that
there are so many people
right now that want to hear from you on
multiple levels but particularly what
the the future of restaurants looks like
and what we can do to help
because we know right now that so many
restaurants
are suffering uh and you're in better
position to
to know what that looks like from the
inside than just about anyone
well i i i can tell you that you know
uh use uh
with a new york times article
uh talking about wild sun
restaurant in new york alone in
manhattan
they were doing okay
by by having tables outside
taking the sidewalks and sometimes
looking like the restaurants are doing
okay under the circumstances the reality
that this new york times article uh was
bringing
to light was that almost 87
of the restaurants are not able to
fulfill the rent payments
uh these this brings
reality that the restaurant industry
uh uh more than how
500 000 restaurants across america that
their
restaurants independent independently
owned
many of us we had to close first because
our cities
our states mandated to do so
but i would say also was the right thing
to do specifically in the moment that
nih and cdc was not even giving us very
good
very good idea what was going on or
the white house and and beyond so to
close down was the right thing to do but
this has
put a lot of hardship not only in the
restaurant industry
and with that i don't mean the owners
alone that they have a lot of
responsibilities
i have almost 30 restaurants at the
beginning of this pandemic
i had to close three or four because was
there a smart thing to do
restaurants will not open again out of
1600 employees
right now uh we have 450 back but
still we have uh many more that that
unfortunately still we we cannot rehire
because some restaurants remain close or
or we don't have a space to bring
everybody back unfortunately
and this is the reality that beyond the
restaurant owners is the
is the millions of uh
americans that work out of the
restaurants directly that they are out
of
of a job and the many other restaurant
jobs the restaurant industry creates
farmers many of them they they've been
having a hard time
uh selling their fruits and vegetables
to
to to other people because restaurants
we were the main
output of their production fishermen
clam
clam fishermen lobster fishermen you
name it all across
so this has put the burden beyond the
restaurant industry directly
indirectly the many men and women the
millions
that fit america every day and
and this is our reality the fall is
coming already
we know that this pandemic is still we
didn't win
that is still we're going to have a few
hour months ahead where the restaurants
uh as uh the weather is going to get
colder we're not going to be able to see
it anymore
outside and and
inside it doesn't make a lot of sense
even if they tell you do whatever you
want
let's face it i want to have my team
safe
their family safes and even if the
government or the mayors tell me 50
my restaurants i'm not gonna feel them
more than 30 percent
or if i keep them open at all so the
hard reality is
the russian industry is suffering uh and
we need the full support of the federal
government to take us through these hard
times we make
more than 12 14 of the
of the jobs and the gdp of america in
more ways than one
we need to be supporting uh the
restaurant industry we have a bill
uh which is called the restaurant act
that
we are requesting uh over a hundred
billion dollars to be supporting the
restaurants through these hard times
because i cannot see an america going
back to economic growth
next year if the restaurants are not
part of the solution
well i know that i could not agree more
that small businesses and restaurants in
particular are the life's blood
of so many communities and that there
will not be a comeback
so can you tell us more about the
restaurant act uh
and um and walk us through the decision
making so
um we've been in the midst of this
pandemic now for
six months i agree with you obviously
it's not ending anytime soon
and you had to make a host of very
difficult decisions around different
teams different restaurants where it
sounds like you've closed several for
good but of the 70
many you hope to reopen um you've
reopened many
under a limited capacity where it sounds
like you've brought back about 30
percent of workers
uh and they're they're likely doing a
lot of takeout
and curbside they're not bringing people
in so
what does the decision to
keep a restaurant open look like how
flexible have you found landlords to be
in terms of let's say those 87 percent
of restaurants you obviously
don't have the revenue coming in to pay
rent uh
if you are a landlord i'm thinking well
okay my this restaurant can't pay me
but if i foreclose on this restaurant
then am i really gonna get a new tenant
in during this time
probably not um but but it seems like a
lot of these
landlords themselves often owe money um
in various ways like they financed their
property
so even if they wanted to forgive the
tenant
they might have a hard time doing so and
i'd imagine you're even having those
kinds of conversations with some of your
landlords
me personally and i know it's been many
people
trying to guide small restaurant owners
that maybe we were not so
good in understanding how to renegotiate
with a landlord we need to understand
that many landlords
are suffering too we need to recognize
these number one
many landlords are maybe
they own the buildings where the
restaurant is but maybe
they have to be paying the bank also uh
the loans on the property they acquire
and we are all together on this
but it makes a lot of sense to
understand that if a landlord
is is not willing to compromise at the
end of the day
that restaurant will end closing and
that landlord is not going to be
finding anybody to take over that that
the space anytime
soon so myself we've been able to
negotiate obviously
i'm very lucky because i have a very
good financial team
around me that brings me wisdom
but we've been negotiating our different
leases
and overall we found good landlords
willing to compromise
and the compromise is all of the buff
from postponing some payments to even
uh taking away a few months off
the table um going maybe from
some fixed random structures to more
percentage fee structure so everybody
commits
it's many options that everybody should
be exploring but i know
it's been good people out there trying
to give small restaurant owners and
maybe they
had the savvy on adapting to these
new situations that can help everybody
used to find compromise i do believe
compromise wins the day and where
the states or the cities through the
mayors can
can do something to bring certain logic
i think will be in the best interest of
everybody i don't see america again
with every single corner every single
storefront
shut down if we want to have
economic growth again we need to
position
the businesses and especially
restaurants to be able to be part
of that economic uh growth post
copied 19th so uh
in the early days everybody is familiar
now with the ppp
which was an early idea that white house
congress put forward
the idea was okay but as we know
um all of the time we realized that
the restaurants we were becoming the
unemployment
facility instead of taking care of the
payroll
uh through the traditional unemployment
office uh all of a sudden the
restaurants were doing this but people
thought that oh this is great this is
coming to the restaurants
well it didn't uh the restaurants uh
i was very happy because we were able to
be paying employees me i was able to get
ppp
again it's good to have a good a good
team of advisors and lawyers and
that knows how to navigate those
waters but many small restaurant owners
didn't had
that power and many of those ppp were
not didn't go to to
a small restaurant owners
so i think a very small percentage
around eight ten twelve percent only
of what we call the independent
restaurant
um the irc uh coalition the independent
restaurant coalition
the vast majority of restaurants didn't
got any ppp
8 at all so the restaurant
act is an act that is being bipartisan
support
which is rare these days but the food
somehow
brings everybody together to the table
uh breaking bread
still means something and everybody
understands the value that
restaurants bring across every community
in america every state
and ppp was more focused to provide
relief
to those restaurants half a million
restaurants
and more all across america the idea was
precisely to give
this grant that they could be forgotten
that will be for the restaurant owners
to be able to pay rent
uh restaurant owners to be able to do
investment into the cost associated
with running restaurants through this
pandemic
the amount of money we have to be
investing on globes
on masks uh is used crazy use
the the new setups outside the
separation between tables
this is extra extra cost in a moment
that the income is not coming
so overall the restaurant act is just
trying to do this to put 120 billion
dollars in the hands of
more than 500 000 restaurants across
where
restaurants can have the freedom to use
it depends
what they need it for so it may be to uh
renovate the restaurant under the new
the new
pandemic others obviously to pay
salaries
uh to pay rent to pay farmers to pay
bills
and i think will be has many other
things i recommend everybody used to
to google uh restaurant act and you'll
see more the details but overall is used
to bring relief
to the more than 500 thousand
restaurants across america
also i've been pushing forward i i was
one of the founding members of of the
irc the
the independent restaurant coalition but
uh i
i very early on i focused myself on
feeding america
and i realized that this was an
emergency
a different type of emergency this is
not hurricane this is not an earthquake
and the restaurants were not affected
was not destruction but we were shut
down
so we had many americans that were
hungry that were about to be hungry
or hospitals that need somebody to be to
be
feeding them who better than restaurants
to do this so world central kitchen
we had almost 3 000 restaurants across
this pandemic
almost 40 million meals where the money
we were
receiving from people supporting our
feeding efforts
what we did was different this time we
began partnering with restaurants
across america more than 40 states and
pay the restaurant so the restaurants
could be open
the restaurants could be employing
people the restaurants could be paying
rent
the restaurants could be buy from the
local farmers
all of the sudden one dollar multiplied
by four
because was covering many other problems
at once
that's why we push for the feed act the
feed act
is simple why we don't recognize that we
have an emergency
that is beyond the economic uh and the
health
emergency it's a humanitarian food
emergency
and by investing in restaurants through
fema
once the emergencies declare supporting
mayors and supporting governors and
where those people especially the mayors
that they are at the front lines
they can be activating those restaurants
to feed
the shelters to feed the hospitals that
they had to shut down the
the the the food operations uh the
homeless
elderly homes first responders it's a
smart idea where every dollar coming
from the federal government
will be multiplied by four tickling down
the economy
and helping everybody you feed the
people in need in the process you
reactivate the economy
that passed congress and there's the
heroes act
pelosi was a big supporter but more
important we had bipartisan support
we had davis in illinois we had thompson
uh we had mcgovern we had uh hurt
who who sees a bipartisan support and in
the senate we had tim
scott south carolina kamala harris
california
we have many more all of the sudden a
good idea that needs the support
past congress is sitting on the senate
but unfortunately
uh the people in charge of the senate
right now is not very interested these
days
in bringing relief to american people
so the feed act is part of the heroes
act is that right
it passed early on uh but as you know
he's been sitting now for weeks in a
month in the senate
it's a great idea you know i when i saw
restaurants
yeah when i saw restaurants uh shift
to feeding hospitals and shelters and
the rest of it
and it employed people i'm sure the
people were eating the meals were
incredibly grateful
and appreciative and the suppliers to
the restaurants so it is a win all
around and it goes to show
what you said earlier which is that
restaurants are so vital
and it should be bipartisan because
everyone loves restaurants who doesn't
love a restaurant
here at yank speaks you know we think
your data
should be yours and not someone else's
uh we're supporting prop 24 in
california if you're listening to this
where we can have higher protections for
your data rights but in the meantime
if you're just doing your thing online
and you don't want
the tech companies and the data brokers
to get a hold of every click
every like every this and that you can
use expressvpn which is something that
the big companies have their people use
it's like beaming into the internet
remotely using a server far away it's
like you're a spy
the spy doing whatever you do nothing
really you know
espionage but hey who knows maybe you
are
who the heck knows and if you were you
might use expressvpn too why not
it's the number one rated vpn according
to
cnet and wired people that know what
they're talking about
say this is it go to expressvpn.com yang
and you can get an extra three months
free on a one year package
that's e-x-p-r-e-s-s-vpn.com
yang expressvpn.com the hope is that our
government gets its act together
and passes real relief so i want you to
paint a picture
let's imagine that there is no relief no
feed act no restaurant act no nothing
um what does the restaurant industry
look like
in let's call it six months with zero
support
um i will see i will say that 40 50
of the restaurant will close forever i
will have
more more of my restaurants that i will
have to make the hard decision of
closing them
because we will get into a debt
that will not make any sense anymore uh
even if the economy will be
strong in 2022 that that we will incur
will be so great
that it doesn't make any sense
and this is coming from you and your
restaurants are stronger
better financed better managed more
popular
more uh predictably
profitable in a normal or good time than
the vast vast majority of other
restaurants that are out there
because uh you know obviously like you
know you
your uh celebrity and your restaurants
are
themselves famous uh in each community
so without aid you'd you'd project that
almost half of restaurants will go out
of business for good
uh i i've seen numbers and
and percentages that they are much
grimmer than
the number i'm giving you i think uh is
a lot of people will not make it
it's it's no way they can make it so
that's why it's so important
that uh um government
on this sense takes over listen i'm a
guy that in that sense
i want to make it on my own uh but
the the the hard reality is that
um um if this keeps any longer
and especially when we know that this is
the right thing to maybe be close but
even if we want to be open uh they are
telling us to close so
under that reality i think it's smart
for everybody to be supporting a
restaurant industry that supports so
much
because will not only be our cities and
our communities that will suffer
rural america will suffer many
many farmers have been talking across
america
especially in the place i live in in
maryland in virginia and dc
some many of the farmers they've been
doing okay because the farmers markets
they've been running very smoothly very
very some of them
unbelievably well run keeping distance
keeping everybody safe
and some of them they've been doing even
better than ever
but not everybody goes to farmers
markets
not everybody has the know-how the
infrastructure
many people rely on usb selling to
restaurants all across
and i know that these many farmers and
many people in the food industry
that dramatically are gonna be
uh being affected already they are but
in the month to come it's gonna be
many people that they're gonna be having
to sell their boat
because they cannot afford anymore to
pay uh
uh to the bank uh there are leases if
they are in the clan business if they
are in the lobster business or in the
in the hollywood business uh all around
everywhere you look
is gonna be people affected directly or
indirectly
because uh the restaurants will suffer
so
better be the congress gets their
their hands together ppp was a good idea
that didn't had the results we wanted
and the restaurant industry we believe
has been
somehow forgotten and that's why it's so
imperative it's so important that the
restaurant act passes
and also i would say defeat act that
while there are two things
that they are totally different at the
same time their company is the same
use invest money in the future of
economic growth for all americans and in
the process
uh be feeding americans in need as you
are putting money back into the economy
again i think will be brilliant
and we need congress to pass restaurant
act and feed that
so for anyone watching this or listening
to this you know imagine
50 or more of the restaurants closing in
your community that would be
catastrophic
on multiple levels not just for
consumers who'd see the restaurant
closed but all the families that work at
that restaurant
to the suppliers and it's not like
anyone's going to run out and reutilize
that space
so the landlords would suffer you'd wind
up with
depopulated retail and ground floor
establishments
which itself would create like a
negative spiral
when it comes to any kind of recovery
so to me it's a no-brainer that we need
to invest
resources in helping restaurant tourists
survive
especially because we can see it's not
anyone's fault
that it clearly is nothing that the
restaurateur
did or didn't do and when i've been out
to these establishments
some of them that have been outfitted
for the pandemic
you could tell that there was some cost
involved because they had to put up
plastic shields and barriers everywhere
but also that that restaurant is going
to be significantly less
revenue generating because having people
sit down and eat
is a good thing and if you have to knock
out 50 or 60 or 70 percent of the tables
or say can't sit here to try and create
distance then you're going to make less
money
and many of these restaurants weren't
exactly
assured of making money even in normal
times so
i i feel like like right now
restaurateurs have so many obstacles
that it's such an uphill battle
and we have to do everything we can to
help them survive this battle
because it's going to be
disastrous for our communities for our
economy for so many
families if these restaurants don't
survive
so one of the great things that
banks and credit card companies and
financial institutions could be doing
right now
will be to be very active
in providing support
to small restaurant owners on
small businesses overall um
we we think like everybody has an
understanding
of of what is a good financial
performance and
an income estimates and but i think now
will be a great moment
to provide that type of support to to
small businesses
owners and especially restaurants i said
that myself i've been very lucky because
i have friends we have
amazing team members that financially
they are very smart
and that makes me look good and makes me
smart but still
i'm going through hardships but i cannot
imagine people that will not have
that support giving
wise advice
on what to do how to negotiate
how when to ask for a loan when not uh
what the what the the right rent should
be how to renegotiate your rent your
lease
etc etc it's very hard it's very hard to
know
uh and one one thing that uh i want to
throw out there that you mentioned
earlier
is that in many of these cases a credit
line
is not enough in the sense that for many
restaurant owners if you just build up
their debt load they'll look up and say
wait a minute i will never pay this debt
back
um i'm going to be working for a
creditor essentially for like the rest
of my
my life like i'd rather shut down so
some of the well-intended measures
around all will lend you money
like that will not keep the restaurant
open in many cases
uh 100 agree we saw it with ppp that
uh ppp again i repeat it was the right
idea that the implementation was
so so even uh white house kept changing
uh uh we we were we were always behind
it's like all of the time one day you
were okay
and a month later you realize that
you had to pay a big percentage back to
the government
and you are like hold on a second it's
already difficult
to pay back a loan when the restaurant
is functioning properly
imagine how do you pay back a loan when
you have no income
and actually you're losing money myself
for example and i know is many
many more in my industry facing the same
while uh we we we're having income
uh some of my restaurants are between 40
and 60 percent
of the sales compared to lazier not bad
right
but let me tell you uh uh i'm i'm
thankful that we're doing that but again
it's only 40 60 percent uh uh
and and still uh week to week month to
month we are not making money we are
actually losing money
why i wrap preferably open because i can
be employing people
because i can keep paying the lease
because
i can keep buying from the farmers uh
sometimes
you look yourself at the mirror and you
say wouldn't be better
use to to shut down
and and use
just wait um but
i believe that being open is so many
more people we can be employing
even i guess it's a risk because covet
is around
and kobit is a reality and
and and complicates things in ways we've
never experienced before
so again yes this is going to be hard
for everybody that's why we need
a white house that recognizes the
problem we're facing
and when you have a leader that seems
not even to recognize we have a pandemic
and seems not to recognize how many
businesses are suffering
and who instead of coming up with smart
ideas and bills
to invest into solutions seems is
throwing money at the problem
we've been paying farmers across america
the big farmers
because very bad policy in
the white house fight with china where
actually now
we are not better off maybe the
president is showing
everybody how strong he is against china
but right now we've
spending more money paying subsidies to
our farmers that they are not even
producing food
because the war with china we've spent
four or five times
in those subsidies to farmers that we
spend when we had the
automobile crisis and is not creating
jobs
is only throwing money at the problem
the president looks good but he's really
writing checks to farmers
in the process we are not feeding
america this is to me
insane that's why we need policies
that they don't look that they're good
so you can get votes on election day
but policies that empower americans
to do well all across we need a white
house that
recognizes the pandemic until we don't
have that leadership in place
everything is going to be hard because
we require
a very big approach idea
to have a big investment to regrow the
economy
towards 2021 2022 and right now i don't
see that leadership in the white house
or
in the senate well you know i'm on board
jose that
we need a different uh set of leaders in
the white house and uh hopefully we can
turn the page
for our country on november 3rd or
[Music]
thereabouts
all right holiday season is around the
corner which means given that maybe
you're not visiting everyone that you'd
like to visit you might be mailing them
stuff
before you might go to the post office
but now you really should check out
stamps.com
we use stamps.com all the time on the
campaign
it's like having a post office on your
computer and now it includes ups
so it's like usps and ups all in one
on your computer you can print
everything you need just stick it on the
box
no need to wait in line it is glorious
and there's no risk with my promo code
yang you get a special offer that
includes a four week
trial plus free postage and a digital
scale
the scale is not that big you can't
weigh yourself but you can weigh
packages
and that's really all the scales for so
go to stamps.com
click on the microphone at the top of
the home page and type in yang
that stamps.com enter yang so i just
voted
and in order to like a mail-in vote in
order to do a mail-in vote you actually
have to provide your own stamp
so just use stamps.com to get my stamp
so uh if you're voting you may want this
because i don't know how many of you
have stamps lying around your house
or apartment or wherever you are so
stamps.com
stamps.com enabling democracy since
2020.
so i have to to comment on your t-shirt
i think it says immigrants feed
uh america which i could not agree more
with
and you have such an incredible personal
narrative yourself
you came to this country with next to
nothing
you worked in a restaurant i know you've
been back and forth
to spain and the u.s but you
your work just kept on drawing more and
more
fans and support and uh everywhere you
went people
um wanted to to taste your food really
but you know is so much of it uh and i
feel like your
immigrant story is like the story that
so many people came to this country
to have a chance at themselves just to
try and create a better life for
themselves and their families
uh and i i'm the son of immigrants
myself
uh and you know i know you've had your
run-ins with
our current president hopefully outgoing
president
over the fact that you were supposed to
have a restaurant in one of his
establishments
and then you said you know what i don't
think i want to have a
restaurant in this establishment and
ended up
um like uh on the other side of the
the president there which i i commended
your
or like i like many americans thought
that you were
awfully uh principled and courageous to
make that stand
but i'm sure there were some negative
effects as well that you had to deal
with
well let me tell you imagine the day i
wake up
and the president
of united states is suing my company and
myself personally
and actually because i was the right
thing to do i saw him back
how many times you have a president of
the united states that is in a zoo with
a citizen
i think it's a first but i did it
because i
i sincerely believe that
that his comments on mexicans were used
uh not the right thing to be listening
from a leader
and that the right thing to do was to
stand up
many people told me if you knew he will
become president will you do the same as
a hundred times over yes
i remember speaking with him uh in the
early days of his comments and he told
me don't worry he said everything will
be fine
jose we are winning jose we are winning
i say
mr trump i'm i'm trying to open a
restaurant
i'm not running in your ticket uh i'm
not supporting your ticket
i only want to have a successful
restaurant and i believe that
we the people uh means that we should be
respecting each other
it doesn't seem you're a person that
respect others
and and i hope that you will change and
rephrase
uh your comments i thought he was going
to do something i was so naive
that i thought that a a cook like me an
immigrant like me
could make a person like him maybe to
sound apologetic i don't think that was
naive at all jose
i like like it was quite reasonable of
you to think that he doubled down two
weeks later and he's the mom and dad
so for me obviously you mentioned about
matured
immigrants immigration reform listen as
an immigrant
and as a spanish-american i'm very
thankful about the amazing opportunity
i gained by being invited to join this
country
and by becoming american you
gain a lot of
a lot of things that this new country of
ours gives us
but with with with the with becoming
american
also you gain responsibilities to be a
good citizen
to give back to respect others and to
give back
as much as we receive from the country
that welcome us
but also we need to be aware of the big
lie
that we have on immigration reform that
we need to be also pragmatic we had
chances with the democratic party that
we didn't take
and and is everybody needs to be
involved in passing
immigration reform dreamers is the first
step how is possible that we have almost
a million
americans because they may not have a
passport but to me
sometimes you don't belong to a place
because they give you a paper
you belong a place because you work hard
to belong
those dreamers they are earn our respect
by becoming young citizens almost a
million
is strong do you know how long it takes
to train a workforce of a million
people this is an asset for america
i always said that the immigration
reform is not a problem for
america to solve it's an opportunity for
america to cease
dreamers should be part of the american
dream
today but who people think
is being feeding america through this
pandemic
the people that are that we can afford
to be playing golf who do you think is
taking care of those golf courses
who do you think is refilling the
shelves who do you think is working the
farms
every day from sunrise to sunset
sometimes badly paid badly treated
without any ppe to make them
safe who do you think is the people that
they've been
putting america forward through this
entire pandemic
many americans in the in the middle
lower class that they've been working
day in and day out to provide for their
families but indirectly
to keep america moving but 11 million
undocumented americans i am telling you
they've been in every corner of america
through this pandemic
moving america forward those men and
women they show the value
to america they show that they belong to
america
is about time that once and for all we
pass comprehensive immigration reform
america will win republicans and
democrats will win
because we all know and undocumented
they are part of our lives
our our communities is about time we do
this and i hope this pandemic
towards 2021 will give the opportunity
one day
soon enough to pass immigration reform
to allow dreamers to belong
and become american citizens and why not
to give the opportunity to undocumented
immigrants to have a legal status in
this country
it's heartbreaking that we have missed
the opportunities we've had jose
you know that there were windows when
bipartisan legislators came forward and
said we need
a comprehensive approach to immigration
and everyone knows it
unfortunately many politicians now
feel like it's more advantageous to them
to have something to get make people
upset
uh than it is to to reach across the
aisle and
hammer out like some kind of compromise
or bipartisan approach
and we're seeing that in and on multiple
fronts unfortunately now with a pandemic
but immigration to me has to be
very very high on that list of things
that americans know that
we need needed years ago to have
a more rational approach a humane
approach
a more clear-eyed approach for the
reality of the fact that so many of our
communities rely upon
immigrants every single day uh and so
your t-shirt is very apt
[Music]
so i messed up my shoulder because i'm
learning i'm learning how to golf and
i'm horrible at it the angle i sleep at
at the moment is very very important and
i'll put it this way my old mattress
would have been a disaster
but my new one has been wonderful and
that's because my new mattress
is from helix sleep how helix sleep
works guys is you go online we basically
found a survey on how you sleep
and then they match you with the
mattress um and they ship it to you in a
couple days
um and it comes in this very tightly
wrapped box easy to get into your home
and bang pops open
next thing you know you have one of
those comfortable matches you've ever
slept on the other thing is you have a
10 year warranty and you get to try it
before you buy it
in the first 100 nights so if you don't
like it you're good
you can get off it we've got something
good for yank speaks listeners helix is
offering up to 200
off all mattress orders and two free
pillows as well for our listeners at
helixsleep.com
yang that's helix h-e-l-i-x-sleep.com
you get 200 bucks off your first
mattress
the number one best overall mattress
pick of 2019 and 2020 according to gq
and wired magazine so can you imagine
doing that article
you just freaking just sleep on a bunch
of mattresses and say the best one
helix sleep
[Music]
[Applause]
it's so inspiring to me to see someone
like you who's come here
made so much of yourself but then also
thrown yourself into
multiple important causes right now
fighting for restaurant tours
uh for immigrant rights but also you've
led many humanitarian efforts around
food and food scarcity and food relief
um someone said to me when they found
out that i was gonna be talking to you
that it's like everywhere there's a
crisis jose is where you're like you're
like this uh
the the this food saint who's like just
trying to deliver food to people who
need it
uh and to me that that's such like a an
american
story where it's not like you were
content just to become an
enormous success which you you know have
been for years
but that you're fighting for people
other than yourself and you're fighting
for things that are bigger
than just your businesses
well i i always said that people like me
would feed the few
but people like me we should be also
involved in feeding the many
uh when you have a fire you send
firefighters and they do
an amazing job putting their lives at
risk we've seen it right now in oregon
california
in every one of our cities when
buildings collapse
we send first search and rescue
responders
when you need to provide help to people
after
a hurricane or earthquake we send teams
and
of doctors and nurses and even we do
field hospitals
um but i realized that then
when you have to be feeding people after
an emergency we should
be sending the best people who knows how
to feed people
which are cooks this to me came
early on in my life when i was uh
i realized that haleo on 7th honey my
first restaurant in washington dc
back in 1993 that across the street from
where haleo is
was the missing soldier's office that
was found few years later
the missing soldier's office was the
house
and the office of mrs clara barton
the woman that single-handed was taking
care
of the wounded during the american civil
war and is the woman that thanks to her
created the american red cross
my father and my mother were nurses uh
to me was very simple to say we need to
be involved in more cooks
what happened in katrina what happened
at the superdome
was never supposed to be happening if we
had a very good
unified response to the
hunger food and water needs
of americans so guess what
i realized that we are millions of
restaurants across the world
and even if i don't know every
restaurant owner every chef
in every city restaurant people in a way
we know each other
and when you say you're a chef and
you're a restaurant it's almost like
it's this kind of of family connection
so i realized that we could be
activating restaurants and food trucks
anywhere
in a moment's notice when beirut
explosion happened
a few weeks ago the world central
kitchen teams were on the ground
in 24 hours within seven
within 48 hours we had 10 restaurants in
the perimeter
of ground zero where the explosion
occurred
providing tens of thousands of meals
to people that lost their homes to
volunteers
to first responders to hospitals
that's what we did we brought the entire
restaurant community
everybody we organized the systems we
were able to support the restaurants
we created the systems of distribution
everybody thinks that we are cooks that
cook food yes
that's a must but what we are very good
is
in creating the distribution systems
if you have assets but you don't have
distribution
equals you have nothing sometimes i know
i'm very
i'm very critical of fema the men and
women
of fema are heroes to me they're good
men and good women
the national guard the first responders
but
the organization the entity of fema
has sometimes the people handcuffed
fema has to live to its destiny
i am not the one that put the word
emergency in fema
when you have the word emergency means
that the urgency of now in respect to
food and water
is now if you fail to provide food and
water to americans in need
not only sometimes days sometimes weeks
you are failing the american people
so yes what we do is trying to
understand that food is today
water is today in bahamas we were able
to land
when still dorian the hurricane was
northern
of granbaum we were able to land already
in marsh harbor abaco within five days
we reached
80 000 meals a day distributed through
14 islands how when
all the kitchens we were planning to do
north and bahamas were destroyed
we don't have a plan because when you
plan too much
you freeze why because in emergencies
nothing goes
ever as you plan so the best tool is
adaptation
and embracing complexity so we got six
helicopters we go to siple
two sea planes we got one boat with two
helipads
that had jet fuel so we could refill the
helicopters
before a week we were feeding all the
islands
every day not only bringing food but
bringing water filtration systems
for desalination of the sea water we
were able to bring medicines generators
we were able to do 50 medical
evacuations
we are cooks we are a small organization
of 40 people
we were able to do more than 3.5 million
meals
when the big organizations were still
frozen
having meetings about how to operate
sometimes i believe that the best action
in emergencies is
boots on the ground learn and firsthand
what's going on
not from the top of a helicopter but
boots on the ground
listen from the locals watch the
situation
you are able to effectively adapt on
the ground at the moment and be covering
the needs of the people in real time
that's what we are trying to do about
central kitchen and that's what we hope
we will keep learning to be better every
day as
unfortunately uh we are needed i hope
that when they were central kitchen will
go out of business
but emergencies we know they are always
going to happen we are not technically
a hunger organization we are more a
first responders food organization
and and we know that our europe is
necessary
to bring americans together to bring
people of the world together and start
feeding people
right after an emergency happens that
kind of
nimble entrepreneurial approach is so
necessary
especially in a real-time crisis and
what you just described to me reminded
me of the saying that i know you know
well jose which is
amateurs discuss strategy professionals
discuss logistics
where you immediately just go straight
to what do we need
how do we get it there like what is the
distribution channel
how are we going to actually get the raw
materials in
for these kitchens uh that's exactly the
kind of
approach that is so helpful in a crisis
because like you said the reality on the
ground never looks like the way it did
in the conference room anyway
you know you have to get to the ground
and it reminds me of
some of the experiences i've had too
where
one of the things that i'm passionate
about right now jose is that our country
is getting bogged down in bureaucracy on
so many levels
and then people are just getting more
and more frustrated because things
aren't working the way they're supposed
to
uh and uh at a restaurant you have no
choice but to make it work
like with uh your organization you're
like well our entire job is to
uh figure out how to make it work
and we need more of that uh it's
and i'm going to say that
entrepreneurial spirit is something that
i spent years trying to cultivate to a
higher degree
um in young people and entrepreneurs
around the country
because it's so important and if we lose
that substance then we're sunk uh you
know and i think it's one reason why
your passion for
helping restaurateurs is
exactly the right cause the right fight
right now because
each of those restaurant owners
like is like their own uh
like they're they're fighting their own
battle you know but but they're but
they're each
like real battleground leaders you know
like they
they figure it out every single day uh
and
we need to give them a chance to succeed
um because they they're so important to
their communities
um and we can talk about the economics
and the food and the rest of it but
really just the humanity of it that
these are people that uh just
make good things happen in their
communities every single day
that's what we need to make sure stays
alive here in the united states
i i think you're right i think was
western churchill that said that
success is going from failure to failure
without losing
enthusiasm but to have a failure also
you have to be there
to risk to take
to take the risk other will not even
take because
it's easier to be in the comfort of what
you know versus
going out there and trying to move an
idea forward
that that sometimes you don't even know
if it's going to work because you have
a gut feeling and you prepare as much as
you can but
still you don't know if the great idea
you have
is ever going to happen but you have to
be taking the risks
one thing about this pandemic is trying
to feel good and take care of yourself
it's not easy
uh zakir went on a health kick that
lasted about a month and then uh he's
been struggling ever since
yeah but one thing that you can commit
to doing
that will help you feel better and
be healthier is athletic greens over the
course of my life
i have put a lot of different mixes and
shakes into my body
and athletic greens uh truly makes a
difference in a way that the other ones
have not
it you you imbibe it and it actually
feels like you're helping yourself
uh and the science bears it out the
nutrition bears it out
it's like a super multi vitamin and if
you want
to boost your immune system feel like
you're treating your body well
in a way that's actually sustainable for
just about anyone
athletic greens is for you so make an
investment in your health today
try the ultimate all-in-one wellness
bundle support your immunity get health
and energy by visiting athletic
greens.com
yang you'll receive up to a year's
supply of liquid vitamin d for free
with your first purchase in case you're
not getting enough sun check it out
athleticgreens.com
[Applause]
obviously we're talking is the
is the confluence between business and
then a non-profit right but
what central kitchen was obviously
trying always to bring this idea of the
for-profit business
in the approach right so uh in the same
way i tell you that we are an emergency
organization uh i try to bring
the the spirit of the entrepreneur
once the emergency goes away like in the
case of puerto rico
uh after maria and the four million
meals we did
uh puerto rico was changing to the
reconstruction mode
where central kitchen didn't disappear
from there now we have a great team that
can respond
has responded to other hurricanes or
earthquakes
but we were able to be investing
in a plan we have to
help over 200 farms to make
sure that the young people of puerto
rico will not leave puerto rico
but will stay in puerto rico creating a
system of food production all across
puerto rico
creating jobs giving a sense of
community
making sure that puerto rico will stop
importing
more than 90 percent of the food they
consume why they will have in a
you know in a in a place that is a
rainforest
be bringing languages from california or
from florida
when they can be growing their language
is right there and
specifically for me it never made a lot
of sense that you will plu
you will put on a plane or on a ship
leverages that have zero calories at
least if you're gonna be moving food
move something like has a calorie to
show off
cover some some lettuces that they have
zero calories and you are using planes
and ships
to move them all across the nation all
across from another
continent it didn't make any sense to me
so we are doing the same environments we
are now helping some of the farmers that
lost everything so so for us
the supporting entrepreneurs we know is
very important
because you are rebuilding the backbone
of a better tomorrow
and so out of these emergencies is where
we help but we are
learning so much of the locals and the
locals tell us what they
they need and what their dreams are that
we try to be there as an ngo
behind them and the money uh that people
donate to us
we try to make sure that doesn't keep
going to
fight the to invest it into the problem
but to invest into the solutions
and now we we began seeing a lot of good
things happening in puerto rico
when i go back and i see all these
hundreds of families that they have a
living
that they're bringing local foods that
they are feeding the local puerto ricans
creating jobs and giving a sense of
community and if something else happened
well we we we are rebuilding in case
another hurricane comes
uh so we have greenhouses that the way
they are built
they will be able to be supporting a
hurricane agree
and this for us is also very important
rebuild generate jobs again
re-engage into the economy but also
rebuild
smarter so when something else happens
you can start moving ahead in the moment
the hurricane goes away
and start feeding your fellow citizens
and put in the economy quicker and
faster
working again jose we should put you in
charge of something massive i mean
you're already in charge of something
massive and you create massive things
but
if there was a government role that
somehow
someone could uh enlist you for
what would you select if there was such
a thing and it could be that there's
nothing in the government that
that interests you because um you've
already got so much
uh on your plate
listen uh it's so many areas of uh
government that um i do believe
can be improved without without hard
work or
huge crazy policies
i do believe that female response can be
improved dramatically
i sincerely believe that fema can do
more with less and i have a feeling like
right now
they are doing less spending more
and i say this sincerely because i've
seen it
in first person many times over
i believe that the farm bill can be
improved
i think the farm bill right now use
throws money at the problem
makes americans sicker makes americans
obese and father
doesn't doesn't that it doesn't
tickle all the money the farm bill has
across every single farm
seems that the farm bill is only helping
the same very super big companies
i like big companies i want to have a
super big company one day
but i don't want to have that successful
super big company
at the expense of middle and smaller uh
farmers being not able to survive
this is not a smart for america if you
are giving subsidies to
the people doing the five four five six
big
cereals and grains [ __ ] why the people
doing carrots and
broccoli are not able to get the same
soup cd
why the usda through the my plate is the
government
telling us what a good healthy diet
should be
but then when you see the my plate which
the government is telling
this is what you guys should eat but
then you see the soup cities and the way
the money at the farm bill is
is spent has nothing to do with that
usda
issue my plate nutritional guidance of
how to fit america
let's make sure that at least we make
common sense
of what the government is telling us
what to eat
and the money they invest to achieve
that objective sometimes we have things
that don't work and don't make any sense
when it should be so easy every single
child in america should be having
a school lunch remember that we began
this in 1946 when generals
uh they asked congress to support
feeding better quality
food because we had young americans that
they were not fit
to join the military because
malnutrition right now we have almost
the same thing
let's make sure that the federal
government and when we have a government
is there to make sure that they invest
in the solutions
not to keep moving the problems forward
on
and on it's like hitting the can down
the road let's stop hitting the can
let's get that can and let's do
something with that let's use it to plan
something from there you can start
fixing a lot of problems
food deserts we keep talking about food
deserts food deserts is something
like the federal government can end in a
day
with help of federal government state
level and mayors
we can eradicate food deserts across
america creating on federal land
businesses small farmers coming to
communities that are forgotten
making sure that people can use it
through snaps the food stamps making
sure that we are able maybe to subsidize
the price so
the price is slightly lower and people
can afford it
people that want our pity people want
our respect let's create systems that
gives
respect to people and in the process you
will restart
local economies you bring wealth to poor
communities
it's so many things we can be doing and
quite frankly uh the thing i'm asking
vice president biden and any candidate
uh that will one day
run in the white house and i know we'll
see you uh one day
trying again uh to to make it one day
uh uh and i wish you the best in the
years to come because you'll be a great
leader in many ways
i've been asking vice president biden
that we need to take food seriously and
we need to have
a person seated next to the president
at the national security level to say
food should not be a problem but an
opportunity
for one day we will not have enough food
not to feed the wall maybe to fit
america because a pandemic will happen
because a pest will happen because a
drought
will happen where taking food for
granted should be
given more importance more seriousness
and if we do that
many many solutions will show up to make
sure
that the problems move away i love it so
much jose what i
am to universal basic income and
eradicating poverty
you are going to be to food security and
eradicating food deserts
and we should totally do what you
just envisioned it would be a massive
opportunity as you say
it's exactly the kind of thing we need
to try and jump start our
communities our economy our own health
like our kids futures i love it
you're a visionary and we're going to
hopefully have a chance to work on these
things together
so the restaurant act the feed act
world central kitchen what else should
we be doing to help you
aside from trying to get our
men and women of congress to get their
acts together and
enact real relief for restaurant owners
well uh
i think uh so many things that are
little that we cannot be helping right
use registering to boat and boating and
voting for
somebody i'm voting for somebody that
brings
empathy forward and brings america
together forward
that's a simple thing to do i'm not
going to tell you who you should vote
for but
you can guess who but both for empathy
and vote for somebody that has put
america in a good path
before with the previous president
that's a simple one
people can be wearing a mask and make
sure that we don't
add more sick people to the lease that
overwhelms our hospitals and put the
lives of nurses and doctors
in danger take a look how simple who can
be against that
who can be against that simple sacrifice
that you can be
we don't have a problem when we go to a
ski and it's cold and we put up
so [ __ ] this is like a long winter use
play the game take care of your fellow
citizens
be and then obviously myself
wall central kitchen uh you know um
we've been
uh spending the money before we get it
if anybody thinks
the way we do it uh is something people
like to be part of
go towards android kitchen the torque is
always a great place to be
and and and
and that said and if anybody is thinking
about
being a restaurant owner now is a good
time uh
it'll be a lot of restaurants out there
that will take
uh a a good smart investor somebody that
had the dream of owning a restaurant
now is the moment in more ways than one
people can be bringing their savvy
especially if people are good on numbers
and investments
and and you can be saving the life of a
local restaurant somewhere
across america only because you are
bringing a little bit of your cash
you own a restaurant your dream is
fulfilled and you bring your know-how
and you give a chance to the restaurant
and that family is working out of this
restaurant
in the future is many ways to be helping
everybody always ask me about jose i
don't know what to do
everybody has talents look within you
look yourself at the mirror
and use give more importance to what you
know
that maybe the importance to you give to
yourself
remember that lives always starts at the
end of your comfort zone
everybody right now should move away
from their comfort zone
and they should be saying it's a talent
i have
that can be helping others let me find
who are those others
that i can help them improve their
future their outcomes their lives
everybody can so just find your way it's
plenty of ways
in this uh center in this country of
ours to be helping fellow americans in
need so
you think about it it's something inside
every one of us that
you will surprise yourself you have a
talent that can
improve the lives of others because you
need to find it because
i know you have it i know these people
there will be thankful
that you knock on their door offering
your support and your help and your
know-how
jose that was incredible i i thought
that you elevated food but what you
really do is you elevate people
uh so congratulations uh on
helping us think more
and act more towards our
community members our neighbors and the
people are working in restaurants every
day
but also just to to realize that there
are so many things that unify us and
food
would have to be very very high on that
list uh and
you're such a unifying figure i i can't
i came into this conversation a fan uh
but now
i'm just thinking wow like there is no
limit to what this man
uh can accomplish the impact that he's
already had and can have
and we need to take your vision and make
it a reality we need to
eradicate food deserts in the united
states of america
and start there because it'd just be a
massive opportunity in improving our way
of life
thank you very much andrew thank you for
having me thank you very much for your
service
uh to all america by bringing your voice
forward uh you show us what is to move
away from your comfort zone probably you
could be doing great
just running your life and being a been
successful in your life but you decided
to be there
to bring your voice thank you very much
because that was important
and many of the ideas you were bringing
forward there are great ideas that
we hope one day they will see the light
and uh
again thank you for your service and
your commitment
to believe that we all can make america
better use by showing up thank you
oh i appreciate it jose and i got to say
when you talked about just showing up
and then figuring out what the reality
was on the ground for world central
kitchen it reminded me of my
presidential campaign
because it was like you draw up what the
campaign is supposed to be
to be like oh man let's get myself to
iowa and see what's going on i'll just
like take a drive to new hampshire
and then you just like ended up adapting
and uh
figuring things out um so you know so
that that's what came to mind for me
like it really was just the
entrepreneurial spirit where you just
think like oh well
like i'm only gonna be able to know what
i need to do if i go out and start doing
it
[Laughter]
thank you jose stay safe and yeah
restaurant act feedback let's get them
into lawn let's get these restaurant
owners the help they deserve
let's make it happen thank you thank you
for listening in i hope you enjoyed this
conversation
if you did please do subscribe to yang
speaks and click on notifications so we
can let you know
every time we have a new episode
you